a lady asked me a question last week
this week she came here from Australia
to interview in Armenia laid a very good
interviewer as well as well she said how
do you deal with family and relatives
who criticize you and say stuff about
you how do you manage that I said you
know what's crazy
I used to spend a lot of time thinking
about that in my 20s but what became
exciting for me is the following you
have to expect them to say things about
you they have to say it it's expected
it's natural but if you try to go
correct them that you're right and
they're wrong that's kind of like a high
school senior varsity basketball player
going and beating a seventh grader what
are you doing you're a bully yeah and
you're playing into the narrative you
don't need to do that what is a
beautiful thing is the following thing I
I tell you what kind of criticism I love
she said what's that I said when a
person two or three levels about above
you calls you out or gives you a sincere
compliment if a person two three four
five levels above you calls you out you
know what they're saying they're
indirectly telling you they are they
fear you being at their level one day
let me say that one more time so imagine
a guy
you're doing a million year he's doing
three million year you're doing 10
million a year he's doing 17 million a
year you're doing 100 million a year
they're doing 340 a year I remember one
time I got a call
from one of the largest insurance
company in America that's been around
for 168 years it's based out of New York
maybe you know what insurance company
I'm talking about and they said in their
board meeting they mentioned you and you
came up
and I sat there and I said that big of a
company is talking about a nine-year-old
company that's amazing then I got a
public letter sent to me from a Theo of
a very large Insurance competitor
publicly he sent that uh letter that he
sent to me he sent it to everybody so
everybody was posting it on social media
and I have this famous Facebook response
term which you have to see it it's very
entertaining and I brought up his golf
score I brought up all these other
things and I told them if later on in
life you ever try to apply for a job for
us I'd love to interview you and I
really went at it because it was like 2
30 in the morning but these are moments
of confirmation where the opponent was
bigger than you says I fear him he's
coming it's a validation so
this is a game we're playing and if you
really are playing the game to kind of
mix it up those are the moments a
competitor
uh just looks forward to I love that and
it's probably what fuels you too at a
certain level if you only knew man
that's uh
foreign